oh good morning because my eye is
not so good 6 a.m right now per se at
comic-con here we go
we are in a box suite right now i'm
getting my makeup like a little bit
makeup done my friend jessica i can't
even talk this morning what's up girl
diana hi hi good morning we have
matching fanny packs now did you bring
yourself i got a stud
and then there's mine it's great my eye
was super bloodshot earlier but now it's
all healed are you ready for this
about your seventh year hearing my
stormtrooper costume
we are on our way over to the convention
center we've got the whole crew
jeremy you ready for this oh i'm ready
uh yeah how many comic cons have you
been to
ha uh this will be the 10th comic con i
produce and i think the 18th comic con
i've been to we are all in good hands
how is
he honestly walking in that and jumping
twirling
this is the official snake handler here
at the indiana jones snake pit now how
many snakes are in here 46 and if you
think a few things i saw i was like i
don't like that guy's moving over there
some fake cobras we just checked out the
snake pit now indiana jones is releasing
all of their films to blu-ray dvd which
i'm the kind of person that i want to
watch everything all in a row so i'll
tell you what i plan on doing well i
actually have a blu-ray player so
great love it
how did you get on your back do you have
help or yes
how long did it take you to get all that
painted uh i woke up at six
that is some skill right there should we
do that tomorrow francisco
yep yep
so just wondering if you guys prefer
this car
oh
this car busy freaking day this place is
crazy we're leaving the show floor now
to go head over to the hard rock to do
some interviews and then who knows what
else is going to happen the rest of the
day but don't worry because i'm bringing
you guys with me
what's up guys i'm here with mila kunis
michelle williams and xamarin you know
you guys have been working on a little
movie come tell me a little bit about
this it's entitled obviously great and
powerful as far as uh these two problems
so we just got done interviewing mila
kunis michelle williams and sam raimi
who are releasing a new movie march 8th
the prequel to the freaking wizard of oz
comic con is still going on
it's just insane it gets bigger and
bigger every year how are we holding up
cheers this right here is by far the
highlight of my comic con this is
chopper
is he going to the bathroom that is so
awesome you have trouble walking down
the street
chopper on the internet talk with the
biker dog
good enough for me
he's like i don't want to drive anymore
i've been driving all day
so i finally got done shooting with this
bike for today there's another full day
shooting tomorrow but guess who i found
mr rishi what's up guys how's it going
you may remember rishi from on the
street in austin it's a lot less humid
here
what are we looking at look at that
piranha 3d it's ugly
don't you hate it can you imagine no
it's sweet can you imagine going up
against that on the water
50 something we're almost there let's
walk faster look who we have so so
swagged out
come on give it a little spin a little
spin oh you guys are so so happy happy
that's where we're at we have everything
and you probably see me wearing probably
every one of these objects i wore this
at disney
do you guys remember that
wow there's so many
awesome toys bring day one to a close
here at comic con i'm exhausted i need
to go to bed early because tomorrow is
gonna be a ridiculously long day
you